et nous accueillons nos invités du
samedi 20 heures ce soir nicole et
anne-claire damaggio bonsoir
alors selon le ministère de la santé
l'autisme touche une personne sur 150 en
france le syndrome d'asperger guère que
vous portez anne-claire concerne environ
trente mille personnes c'est une forme
d'autisme dans laquelle les malades sont
dotés d'une intelligence hors norme on
pense que l'albert einstein isaac newton
mozart hitchcock bill gates était
asperger nicole pendant quinze ans vous
avez tout fait pour insérer anne claire
dans la société et vous raconter tout ça
dans un livre intitulé une épée dans la
brume publié chez anne carrière vous
nous raconter votre histoire ah ben
[Musique]
nicole et anne-claire re bonsoir alors
nicole après une enfance et une
adolescence à la fois heureuse et
studieuse vous intégrer l'école des
hautes études commerciales de lille et à
22 ans vous entamer une carrière
professionnelle à paris dans l'industrie
du luxe vous grimpez quatre à quatre les
échelons de votre groupe et vous devenez
bientôt directrice du service export
avec 400 personnes sous vos ordres et
puis un jour alors que vous êtes en
week-end sur vos terres natales dans la
région de saint-brieuc vous rencontré
celui qui deviendra le père de vos deux
enfants
première enfance et anne claire
dès les premières heures de la vie
d'anne claire vous avez une étrange
intuition vous la trouvez très joli très
sage mais aussi trop distante et j'étais
même rassuré qu'elle soit très sage ça
s'est vite révélé comme étant trop sage
pour tout court ça m'aide et facile à la
bonne appétit un sommeil impeccable mais
au fil des mois cette impression
d'impassibilité vous avez une noté au
départ refait surface il ya quelque
chose qui ne fonctionne pas dans la
communication entre nous et à cette
époque bien sûr je présente anne claire
au milieu 5 mai 10 mais tout va bien
alors petit à petit les détails
s'accumulent et vous commencez à vous
poser des questions à nucléaire ne
s'anime jamais tout seul et pour qu'elle
réagisse il faut la stimuler elle semble
voir son regard des halles est absente
elle est indifférente comme si le reste
du monde était un nez en fait mais
j'ignorais qu'elle est quel était son
monde à ce moment là ouais elle
réagissait très bien à moi et à ma mère
et c'est tout en clair à six mois
lorsque vos regards se croisent pour la
première fois là vous avez la preuve
qu'elle voit mais son monde dites vous
la hap aussitôt il y a comme une une
frayeur de voir qui nous sommes
réellement alors vers l'âge d'un an anne
claire comment ça marche et les
branleurs
on comprenait pas pourquoi et en fait
c'est parce qu'elle avait on lui avait
appris à marcher c'est des adultes qui
l'encadraient avait les bras en l'air
elle continuer comme ça voilà alors vous
voyez qu elle naquit rien de manière
naturelle tout doit être décomposé
séquencé expliqué répéter alors
évidemment les gens vous traite à ce
moment-là de mère étouffante en dessous
lui la paix à ta fille quoi on est une
mère qui ne laisse pas son enfant faire
son expérience or je laissais mes
interparti par exemple mais ne revenait
pas ne savait pas pourquoi voilà un jour
votre vie bascule c'est la fameuse
histoire du gravier anne-claire ramasse
un gravier elle rêve c'est que ce
gravier dans la main et s'assoit par
terre oui et elle reste comme ça les
perdu dans son univers oui en tout cas
elle n'était pas dans le nôtre et elle
n'a pas eu le réflexe de demander de
l'aide ou bien de d'exprimer ce qu'elle
faisait et là c'est un autre monde qu'il
fallait que je découvre pas ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'en revanche anne
claire développe un langage extrêmement
bien construit très précoce à ce niveau
là elle employait déjà deux ans des
subjectif qui est quand même très
étonnant vous vous souvenez de vos
premiers contacts avec le monde vos
premiers souvenirs d'enfance
j'ai effectivement quelques souvenirs de
mon enfance
en terme de contacts et autres ce n'est
pas quelque chose auquel j'ai apporté
réellement le soin d'un souvenir
travaillé dix roues puisque j'ai
toujours travaillé quel que soit mon
agent l'intuition raisonnée est certes à
divers degrés selon mes années de vie
puisque je suis je suis adepte de la du
paradigme qui veut que l'on apprenne en
proportion de ses années de vie mais je
me rappelle tout de même de la sphère du
gravier je me rappelle parfaitement tout
de même avoir conscience en partie de ce
que je faisais et je ne pense pas ne pas
avoir eu le réflexe de demander de
l'aide mais je me rappelle déjà à job je
me pense avoir eu déjà cette précocité
en termes de fierté ce que j'appelle
aujourd'hui sobriété est qui et qui
faisait que j'aimais mieux me
débrouiller par mes propres moyens si
limitée soit il plutôt que de demander
de l'aide alors évidemment la précocité
intellectuelle de votre fille vous
encourage visite à l'école ça va être
formidable
malheureusement l'école maternelle
s'avère terriblement compliqué et trois
ans plus tard le verdict tombe et c'est
quelque chose qui vous poursuivra tout
le temps elle serait mieux ailleurs
alors que vous votre seule ambition
c'était de la socialiser mais vous
naviguez à vue en fait vous ne
connaissez pas à ce moment là le
problème dames claire si elle ne l'est
pas frotter au moins dans lequel elle
allait vivre plus tard elle serait de
toute façon éjecté et ça a été la
terreur dans laquelle ge malheureusement
ce mot est fort mais il est réel dans
laquelle
j'ai vécu pour ne pas arriver à cette
extrémité est passé toute mon énergie à
expliquer ce qu'elle avait à trouver des
outils et à faire en sorte qu'ils
restent dans le système alors il ya des
moments excellent c'est à dire un jour
dans une kermesse vous réciter à la
perfection un poème extrêmement longs
extrêmement complexe je me rappelle
effectivement avoir eu déjà tout enfants
le goût du théâtre le goût de la
représentation mais surtout le goût des
symboles
la passion des symboles devrais-je dire
ouais
alors pour qu'elle entre en primaire
vous vous battez vous dites ya une
phrase dans le livre que je viens de
faire échapper ma fille à rien et je
l'emmène dans l'impossible ça a été un
tournant de mon existence puisque j'ai
fait échapper au redoublement de la
maternelle qu'il servait à rien et puis
la mettre dans l'école primaire alors
face à salé tous libres n'ont pas de
réponse j'en profite pour dire que ce
n'est pas une maladie c'est un syndrome
donc un fonctionnement différent atteint
de ce syndrome ont le porte-voix la
wii personnellement j'aurais tendance à
dire qu'il ne s'agit pas même d'un
simple drôle ou kiss kiss ordonnance
autour de symptômes j'aurais tendance à
dire que c'est qu'il s'agit d'une
spécificité alors petit à petit vos
efforts portent leurs fruits par exemple
l'histoire de france qu'elle découvre à
travers la lecture elle devient
obsessionnel de l'histoire de france oui
passionnel de tous explique plutôt je me
réfère en serait très volontiers à la
passion que décrit et jean racine non
pas les passions ni même l'amour
inconditionnel qu'il écrit mais vraiment
la passion à doit pas mal jusque hull
qu'il décrit comme étant le sentiment
qui a acquis tout le flamboiement
alors vous vous êtes évidemment
d'épuiser par ce travail permanent et
l'avait amené à me claire chez un psy et
vous dites ces deux ans de gentilly
conversation
alors le psy vous conseille un centre
spécialisé vous allez voir vous dit
jamais non jamais unie qu'elle soit
socialiser on pouvait pas comme prévu
qu'on me disait qu'elle ne serait jamais
lire écrire et compter et que c'était
son avenir j'ai été horrifié le mot et
je me souviendrai toute ma vie de ce
moment je suis sorti avec elle et j'ai
dit elle sera dans la ville en ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est qu'en arrivant
dans ce on se centre anne claire voie
les autres enfants elle dit au des
humains
ils seraient quelque chose d'extra
terrestres dont ça veut bien dire
qu'elle avait une perception du monde
différent du nôtre sera charge de
trouver qui nous était ce monde et a de
quoi ils étaient constitués
extraordinaire alors en fait le problème
c'est que vous avez du mal et toutes les
solutions devant vous vous avez du mal à
faire un choix non
[Musique]
je ne pense pas que ce soit vraiment
cela tout du moins ne le dirige pas de
cette manière mais il s'agit plutôt de
puisque tout toute vie est une forme
d'art il s'agit plutôt de 6 les sonars
de choix
nous asperger est autiste en général
avant une vision plutôt qu'aller de ce
que pic des choses ce qui ne signifie
pas nécessairement que le détail prime
sur la globalité mais que nous ayons une
vision de mosaïque où nous avons déjà le
motif plénier et non pas forcément total
mais bien plénier est dans son essence
propre en tête et devant les yeux et les
asperger sont globalement doux et pour
presque tout sauf pour les choses
ordinaires voilà c'est le propre du
génie c'est ce qui ressort d'un bus mais
comme l'écrit theo peeters qui m'a fait
l'honneur de la préface d'un livre le
génie et les handicaps se touchent
souvent et nous sommes vraiment dans
cette sphère là alors au collège c'est
beaucoup plus dur un d'abord faut y
aller d pour ça faut traverser la rue et
là vous la fait répéter quoi
pour le feu rouge traverser la rue
regardez-vous lui fait de faire cent
fois les choses pour qu'elles se mettent
bien ces choses très simples dans la
tête en fait tout passe par un
raisonnement intellectuel scientifique
avec la condition qu'ils comprennent et
qu'ils acceptent tous les tenants et
aboutissants d'une même situation
l'intégrer et la pitié or là on s'est
dit très difficile parce que les
adolescents vous dit dans le livre sont
des prédateurs évidemment il y en a qui
la grèce et n'a qu'une insulte y en a
qui disent des obscénités vous avez vécu
ça comme un
jeu lettre 10
je vais très vite assimilé à une veillée
d'armes
d'accord mais surtout peut-être l'auteur
et je leur rends grâce qui m'a peut-être
le plus sauvé durant cette période ou du
moins qui m'a aidé à tenir et jean
raspail et notamment avec l'une de ses
citations que j'aime beaucoup quand on
représente une cause presque perdu il
faut vous dire sur son cheval sonner les
trompettes et 31 dernières sorties sans
quoi l'on meurt au fond de la forteresse
cupules personne n'a siège car la vie
s'en est allé vous êtes dit vous une
mère par bribes parce que vous êtes
évidemment sa maman mais aussi son
éducatrice un psychologue son esclave
son otage sa juge sa tortionnaire en
face à un rapport extrêmement compliqué
la douceur on essaie bien sûr mais il
faut une telle intensité pour les pour
les faire réagir et agir mais qu'on est
obligé d'être très intense alors voilà
et puis un jour en regardant la
télévision vous le découvrez quelles
portes le syndrome d'asperger heures et
là vous êtes un peu soulagés vous dites
ça existe hélas est presque une victoire
je me suis reconnu je me dis mais
j'exige rsjh avez raison c'est ça qu'on
votre maman vous a dit voilà tu es une
star guerre ça vous a fait quoi j'ai
tout de suite en revue les aspects qui
pouvait être désagréable dans ma vie
future j'ai tout de suite vu l'aspect
stigmatisant
mais je me suis
10 puisque j'en avais l'habitude que le
mieux que je pouvais faire c'était de le
fabriquer enfin comment dirais-je de le
leur créer de leur créer de me
l'approprier d'en faire un art de choix
et surtout de le transformer en joue et
philosophiques je me dis jamais asperger
ni différentes ni quoi ni autre chose de
ce genre mais je me dis brodeuses de
brume
alors ses bénéfices comme l'expliquent
entre autres la couleur blanche que je
porte ce soir et vous vous en souffrit y
aider des méthodes de votre mère quand
elle vous dresser à pour traverser la
rue vous c'était insupportable pour vous
comme tout adolescent jeu comme tout
allait donner sans nous avons à coeur de
soigner notre nos effets néanmoins je
suis bien que nos relations ont toujours
été ont toujours été et serons toujours
racinienne dans le plein dans un sens
plus ou moins totale du terme et en ce
sens ma foi l'amour que je lui porte n'a
pas nécessairement besoin d'être
d'être confirmée par une infection par
une affection de monstres à tuer
démonstratif
alors vos efforts de socialisation
s'avère payant vous lui apprenez à
converser à communiquer alors elle
décroche son brevet en fait des études
de communication à l'université de
toulouse ensuite un master de sciences
politiques et vous êtes major de votre
promotion à la sortie
qu'est ce que vous diriez à un couple à
des parents à une maman qui a un enfant
qui porte un syndrome comparables
je lui dirais surtout de ne pas paniquer
et je dirais de
d'expliquer d'aller convaincre ne jamais
abandonner pour obtenir ce qu'ils
sentent en tant qu'institution de
parents ce qu'ils sentent qu'il est bon
de faire pour son enfant
d'une part d'autre part devraient tout
de suite pour un diagnostic très précoce
car c'est ce qui fait défaut en france
nous avons un retard considérable en
matière d'autisme et d'aspe rigueur en
france et ensuite de lutter et de
proposer des solutions pour qu'il y ait
un accompagnement qu'ils soient
parfaitement personnalisé pour que les
asperger et ceux qui ont différence
invisible et ne place légitime à leur
hauteur dans nos entreprises dans nos
sociétés car ils sont capables du
meilleur et nous offre une vision du
monde totalement différente justement
vous projetez commandant l'avenir hunter
tout d'abord j'espère un jour méritait
pleinement lac l'édification d' être
humainement belle ce sera mon premier
objectif
et j'espère que tout le reste va se
redonnant c'est au tour puisque la
première décision vient du coeur et
l'intelligence noir dont nous sommes
tous exposés terre doit faire ce que
notre coeur décide
[Applaudissements]
frustrant bien ça c'est un métier
formidable ça permet de rencontrer des
gens qui n'auraient jeunes de rencontrer
vous avez envie de fonder une famille
d'être maman
ce n'est pas dans mes projets immédiats
mais
partie des choses cette beauté humaine
que vous revendiquez vous l'avez dit
nous le mot de la fin
j'aurais tendance à dire que la
normalité n'est pas le summum de ce qui
peut s'atteindre
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu